LE
A UNIVERSE THEY LIVE IN
THEY DON'T HAVE PERSONAL
CHAUFFEURS SAFELY TAKING THEM T
AND FROM WORK.
YET THE MEDIA CLAIMS TO BE IN
DANGER ON JANUARY 6th.
THE UNIVSE IS SECURE.
WHAT HAPPENS WHEN YOU SEE BAD
THINGS WITH YOUR VERY OWN EYES?
THE MEDIA SAFE BEHIND THE
SECURITY AND ANONYMITY LAUGHING
ALONG LIKE SCHOOLKIDS.
PRETENDING A MASSIVE INCREASE I
MURDERS IS NO BIG DEAL.
IF BAD THINGS D'T AFFECT THEM
THAN THEY DID NOT HAPP AT ALL.
WE DON'T KNOWS WHAT HAPPENS WIT
THE CRIME WAS.
THE EXPLANATION IS THAT THIS
CREATED THE CRIME WAVE AND NOW
THEY ARE COVERING IT UP.
THEY NEED TO CHANGE THE
NARRATIVE AND APPLY RADICAL
POLITICS
A BRUTAL MURDER LOOKS BAD.
BUT THEY FAILED TO DISCRIMINATE
AGAINST THE POOR.
ISN'T THE SUSPECT REALLY THE
VICTIM?
A MISS WITH GENDER DYSMORPHIA.
SOCIETY IS THE CULPRIT AND THE
NEW WAY TO BLAME THE VICTIM.
>> SHE IS LIKE AOME RE
RENOVATION.
MESSY LOUD AND COMPLETELY
PLASTERED.
SHE HAS DISAPPOINTED MORE
SPONSORS THAN THE OLYMPICS.
WHEN HE SNEEZES MY SIDEKICK IN
THE TELEVISION CHAMPION.
JULIE I KNOW YOU ARE TOO BUSY
WORRYING ABOUT TAKING ABOUT
CRIME.
TRIED TO CONCENTRATE.
I KNOW THIS IS HARD.
WHY IS THE MEDIA SO FAR REMOVED
FROM WHAT PEOPLE ARE
EXPERIENCING EVERYDAY?
>> THE MEDIIS SO FAR REMOVED
FROM EVERYTHING PEOPLE ARE
EXPERIENCING TODAY.
THE HIGHEST CRIME RATE INCREASE
IN THE COUNTRY.
DO REALIZE THAT MARIJUANA IS
LEGAL IN WASHINGTON DC.
MAYBE THIS IS THE ALTERNATE
UNIVERSE THEY ARE TALKING ABOUT.
THE REALITY IS THE CRIME RATE I
THE US IS BECAUSE OF THESE
LIBERAL DISTRICT ATTORNEYS.
I HATE TO BE A BUZZ KILL AND
ALSO FIND THAT LEAVING THIS IN
YOUR HANDS WOULD CREATE A
CRISIS.
I WOULD LIKE YOU DUMMIES TO BE
AT THE WHITE HOUSE.
THIS WOULD EXPLAIN A LOT OF
MEMORY LAPSE.
EVENT IN JOURNALISM ALMOST AS
LONG AS I HAVE.
AS LONG AS YOU HAVE BEEN ALIVE.
DO YOU THINK THE PROBLEM IS THA
THE PRESS IS LESS BLUE COLLAR
THAN WHITE-COLLAR?
>> I THINK THAT YOU GET THIS ON
THE NOSE WHEN YOU SAID IT DOES
NOT HAPPEN WHERE THEY ARE.
THEY DON'T SEE T MOST ELOQUENT
WITNESS EVER WITH THE SUFFERING
OF ORDINARY PEOPLE.
BUT THIS IS THE PROBLEM.
HAVE NOTHING AGAINST THE PRESS
SECRETARY.
I DON'T KNOW IF THEY CONTINUE T
USE THIS EXPRESSION.
BUT THEY HAD 200 MURDERS IN
WASHINGTON DC.
IT'S A WONDERFUL PLACE TO LIVE
AND SHE FINDS HERSELF IN A
SIMILAR SITUATION.
>> IT'S ALL ABOUT CRIME AND IT'
FUNNY THAT FOX WHICH IS THE
REPUBLICAN AND MOSTLY RURAL OR
OTHER CITIES.
SMALLER CITIES.
WE ARE THE ONES BRINGING
ATTENTION TO THE THINGS
HAPPENING IN URBAN AMERICA WHER
ALL THE DEMOCRATS ARE.
WHY DO THEY STILL VOTE FOR THE
PEOPLE THAT THEY VOTE FOR WHEN
YOU HAVE THIS HORROR AND PEOPLE
BEING KILLED.
THIS WAS A MOTHER BEING BEATEN
UP BY A CONVICT ON PROBATION.
A WEAPON WITH AN EXTENDED
MAGAZINE.
THEY COME HERE AND THEY WANT TO
SAVE THE MOTHER THIS BEING BEAT
UP BY A DRUG ADDICT AND THEY GE
KILLED.
WE REALLY THINK THIS ONLINE.
THIS WAS IT.
THESE TWO COPS WENT DOWN AND
IT'S GOING TO BE TERRIBLE.
PEOPLE MOCKING THE SUFFERING OF
URBAN AMERICA.
THE TIME HAS COME.
>> I WISH THEY WERE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE.
I KEEP PLAYING THIS VIDEO OVER
AND OVER AGAIN.
WHEN WE COME OUT AND WE SAY
SOMETHING LIKE WE HAVE BEEN
DOING ALL OF THIS CRIME STUFF
AT IT INSTINCTIVELY KES
PEOPLE THAT DON'T LIKE FOX TAKE
AN AWFUL STANCE.
>> I THINK THAT AS A PRESS
SECRETARY YOUR ENTIRE JOB IS TO
MAKE THE GUY WHO LOOK FOR WHAT
GOOD.
THAT'S OKAY AND THAT'S AT
SHE'S TRYING TO DO BUT IT'S NOT
REALLY WORKING ANYMORE.
PEOPLE ARE FED UP WITH THIS.
A FULL AND REGULAR LIFE ARE NOT
WORKING AT THE WHITE HOUSE.
YOU CAN'T GHASTLY PEOPLE OF THI
ANYMORE.
IS TRYING TO DO HER JOB AND
MAKE JOE LOOK HIS BEST.
EVERYBODY ALREADY KNOWS.
THE DECRATS WANT US TO BE
AFRAID  SO MANY THINGS.
THEY WANT US TO BE AFRAID OF
CLIMATE CHAN.
>> I DON'T CARE IF IT IS RAININ
OR SNONG.
IF MY FRIENDS ARE GETTING SHOT
IN THE STREET IS A BAD TNG.
IT'S DIFFICULT FOR ME WHEN I
LOOK AT THE ENTIRE SITUATION.
FIRST OF ALL.
PEPPERMINT PATTY IS AN AMERICAN
ICON.
BUT SHE JUST DOESN'T TALK TO TH
AMERAN PEOPLE.
SHE TALKS TO HER BUBBLE.
THEY TALK TO THE BUBBLE BECAUSE
WHEN THESE GUYS GO OUT TO DINNE
IN THEIR BUBBLES THEY DO IT AND
THIS IS THE WIFE.
FOUR BLOCKS DOWN IS NOT THE WAY.
WHEN YOU GET THIS THEYDON'T SEE
THE THINGS THAT WE DO.
HE'S TWO YOUNG OFFICERS BEING
SHOT.
I COMPARE THIS TO A GEORGE FLOY
MOMENT.
THIS IS NOT OKAY.
THOSE THAT DID NOT KNOW, NOW DO.
THIS MAN WAS A CHILD.
A MAN OF COLOR.
WHY DOES THE UNIFORM TAKE AWAY
YOUR SKIN COLOR?
WHY WE TALKING ABOUT BEING
CONSERVATIVE WHY DOES THAT TAKE
AWAY MY SKIN COLOR.
PEOPLE SAY IT DOES NOT MATTER.
THOSE ARE TWO BROTHERS AT ARE
DOWN.
IT'S THE SAME THING.
IT SHOULD BE THE SAME OUTLOOK.
'S SHOULD BE ALL OF US AND WE
SHOU BE COMING TOGETHER.
>> LIKEWISE MATTER IN WASHINGTO
DC.
THIS CHAPTER CAMOUT CALLING
THESE MANY HEROES.
>> THEY DIDN'T SPEAK OUT FOR AN
OF THE MURDERS LAST YEAR.
NOT A SINGLE ONE BECAUSE A COP
WASN'T INVOLVED.
>> THEY ARE STILL WAITING FOR
HELP.
THE JOINT OF THE SAME SCRIPTURE.
THE OTHER GROUPS THAT ARE TRYIN
TO HELP.
>> I NEED A DRINK